new vaccines continue to emerge in the
battle against covert 19.
the new vaccine made by johnson and
johnson is the first
to prove effective with just one dose
and controversies and disagreements
surround vaccination programs
the european union launched a scheme
that could block exports of coronavirus
vaccines
in this climate it can be hard to know
what information to trust
but factual and reliable information is
vital to creating trust in vaccines
and to overcoming the pandemic ed carr
the economist deputy editor and natasha
loder our health policy editor
provide answers to some of the big
questions about the global vaccination
drive
why are some people hesitant about
taking covid19 vaccines
the vaccine hesitancy's got two
components at least one of which are
people who just don't don't believe in
vaccines full stop
and others who are saying well you know
i don't think this particular vaccine's
been properly tested i might just wait
and see a little bit
you know that second group is very fluid
and and one of the reasons it's fluid
is it depends upon the circumstances in
the particular country
it so happens that in britain the
national health service particular
hospitals
are overrun at the moment and you really
really don't want to
get kovid 19 just now a serious case of
it
so the impulse to get vaccinated is
pretty high but
if you if you're in new zealand you know
which has i don't think any cases at the
moment certainly if they are they're
sporadic
um you could have probably afford to
wait
what role does the media have in
establishing trust
in vaccines i think we have a
responsibility and i think the
difficulty particularly is when you talk
about
adverse events and so you know
in you know in any vaccine trial if
you're jabbing
i don't know 40 000 people you're going
to have people have heart attacks and
drop dead just by chance particularly if
you're working on
60 and 70 year olds if you're giving
them vaccines
and you know it's very easy to sort of
say oh my goodness somebody
dropped dead on this trial right and
isn't this
terrifying um but you know that's for
the regulatory authorities to
investigate and determine if it's
related to the vaccine it's not
for the journalists and so while you
have to kind of cover those
stories sometimes you have to be kind of
careful and say well
yeah but remember that these things do
happen by chance
the mrna vaccines are new how do we know
they're safe
i think it's worth remembering that
although this is a new
platform for a vaccine
that doesn't mean we haven't been
testing these mrna vaccines for quite a
long time because
they've been trying to use them to make
cancer vaccines which are actually
pretty difficult to make and they
haven't been that successful
but they've been trying for a long time
with this platform
um and the reason is is because it's
quite easy to tinker with and
you know when you have cancers they
change a lot and so the idea
is is that maybe you could you know
match the vaccines to the cancer
so um i think you know the amount of
data we have on the platform goes
far beyond what we're seeing in the last
year
um so i mean i would be completely happy
to take
any of these vaccines will the vaccines
work if the virus mutates
i think we're going to have to live with
mutations
um it is impossible to say how
a virus is going to mutate unless
there's new science
that comes comes out but at the moment
when you know you get a mutation it's
really hard to say
what it's going to do and um you know
when i get an email from the news desk
saying there's a new mutation what does
it mean what should we say i say
absolutely nothing basically because we
don't know what it means
but i do think that we will be adjusting
our vaccines
um further down the line because because
it's
it's written in letters rna like dna
um it's easy to edit so that if you get
a mutation
of the of the virus it does you have to
start from scratch
you've got you've basically got the
platform there and you can edit the
you can edit your mrna to reflect the
mutation
um in in the virus so it's a it's not
only clever
it's adaptable reasonably quickly how a
country is deciding how much time to
leave
between doses
with regards to changes to dosing yeah
it's all about trust isn't
it the question is do we trust the
government to be making the best
decision
what they've done in britain they've
made a public health decision that
actually
um they just want to roll out the first
dose to as many people as possible
um so that you raise the level of
protection
that twice the number of people have
from zero to whatever
it is they're getting it may be 70 it
may be 80
you know we don't really know what
they're getting in that intervening
period so the question is
um by reducing it to one dose in the uk
you're increasing the risk that the
virus uh mutates and so there's a debate
about this isn't it it's sort of like
well
and you've got to kind of weigh up the
fact that one person
is getting most but not all of their
protection compared to sort of giving it
to someone who had
no vaccine whatsoever now i don't think
anyone really knows the answer
certainly uh one virologist has said
i think this this raises the risk that
you will get
mutants escaping i'm i don't feel
qualified to judge and i
don't i think the jury is out actually
on that it's very interesting to note
how america where cases are picking up
very badly and death rates have gone to
pick up again
having been you know publicly very very
condemning of britain we'll see if
american hospitals get
overrun whether there isn't more
pragmatism like that
these decisions are difficult there's no
perfect perfect decision
and you have to do the best you can
should vaccines be mandatory for travel
management vaccine is something we've
we've spoken about
um i personally think it's it's highly
unlikely
and counterproductive for governments to
do anything like that there's no
no better way of undermining trust than
saying you're not going to take this
unless i force you to do it
um so if there is anything mandatory
about it it's much more likely to be a
kind of corporate
pressure or something like that you know
we expect people to be vaccinated
before they come to work or whatever it
might whatever it might be
um and that hasn't you know it's too
early so far in vaccination programs to
know whether that's going to happen
i mean the classic um bioethical
view of vaccine passports is that it's
not a good idea
and economists tend to think that too it
tends to be counterproductive it leads
to cheating
and discrimination is not terribly
useful um
so um but that doesn't mean it's not
going to happen all sorts of things
happen
i think the other thing that factors
into this is quarantine and so
if you're going from a country uh with a
high
instance to a low incidence those
countries can and will
ask you to quarantine for two weeks and
so
i think as a way of bypassing quarantine
it's quite likely that they'll say
well if you've got yourself a vaccine
and you've been tested and a vaccine
and a test for the kobit you don't have
to quarantine so i think that is really
likely
i'm edward carl the economist deputy
editor i hope you've enjoyed this film
if you want to read more of our kovid
coverage please click on the link
opposite
and keep an eye out for the jab our new
covet podcast
and don't forget to subscribe
you